social media is changing the
geopolitical nature of the world yet
there's not even going to be a peep
about creative in Social this entire
week not an award not a conversation
[Music]
and build businesses
I'm Thomas Ramsay I'm the CEO on Founder
on neurons which is an applied
Neuroscience company where we use
neuroscience and AI to predict consumer
Behavior 50 of all ads are presenting
the brand in the bottom right corner yep
four percent maximum are paying
attention to that brand yep so that
means that there's a huge loss if you're
doing brand building for that app that
means that about half of all ads will
actually miss the target I got good news
for you I don't need your AI tools 99
are missing you know to your point
you're just talking about the creative
variable yeah you know the thing that
fascinates me is everybody in this town
for this whole week assumes that the ads
are being seen before you even get into
the part of the creative [__] get up
yeah there's the ads are being run and
people aren't seeing them no is there a
way that you can build an AI bot that
can instill common sense into anybody
here this week please because the level
of common sense that's been completely
and utterly eliminated from the ad world
is fascinating
good stuff
[Music]
hi there how are you
both of us were lining up getting
McFlurry a free McFlurry and then a
McDonald's climb walked up three seconds
last year at this McDonald's award the
internal Awards then it's like oh what
are you all doing here so we had a
McDonald's meeting I was like come to
the winner board bring all your CMOS
next time don't invite them hit them
over the head and carry them to the boat
[Music]
all right
listen I just want to thank everybody I
know there's like 7 000 things that
everybody could be doing and so we
appreciate you being here and obviously
for everybody in this room the AI thing
is a very big deal because it's one of
those technologies that is kind of like
oxygen it's here and it's not going
anywhere and it's going to continue to
be a big factor in our universe just
where we are right now knowing that this
is the base this is just the beginning
this is Ask Jeeves what if all these
things that happen in culture are
actually incredibly mappable what's
amazing is if you know how to be a
propped engineer and put into the query
things you can start mapping things that
have historically been magic or gray or
creative and you're starting to make it
black and white that changes the world
like Jack has to come up with his stuff
but like if you put in these are the 700
last top 100 songs that have hit in
culture what is the common thread or
what should i title it we're starting to
really get into a place that changes the
world we've all lived in it's that big
it's not like it can make a picture for
me it's the predictive AI stuff is
bananas thank you for coming and hope to
see you a bunch this week thank you
everyone
it's like super fun to get like the
intellectual Motors going
[Music]
on
so we're continuing with interviews here
live from can lions 2023 what have you
seen happen time and time again at the
unilevers at the Cocos at the Samsung's
what's the mistake that you saw in web
one from Big Brands you know web 2 with
social and mobile and now what you see
in web 3 what's the common cliche
mistake one of the ones that comes to
mind is really navigating the tension
between dealing with the existing
business yes and future proofing your
business for new generations for new
technologies I remember at the very
beginning it took a lot of time for
companies to think that digital was a
thing and then when they embrace it then
kind of destroy it because it becomes
you know everybody does the same thing
and then you use the creativities you
embrace you know new technologies to do
exactly the same thing that you were
doing before instead of thinking how do
I embrace a new technology to do much
more thank you so much thank you Gary
I'm trying to grow up
hello lovely to me thank you so much for
having me of course thank you for having
this on your phone Latonya caught up
with the CEO of creative agency
vaynermedia and asked what AI means for
the sector you know it's not that I'm
looking to disrupt I'm looking to
inspire us as an industry to become
dramatically more consumer-centric you
talk about AI then of course that's one
of the most dominant themes here at the
festival yes there are those who think
that it will amplify human creativity
yes and those who think it will stop it
yes what's your view my intuition is
amplify the concept of Doomsday new
technologies is something that humans
are very good at people like to push
against new things they go into fear
what's going to be bad even in the last
couple of years it's been obvious to me
that this is an enhancer of course
there's going to be things that come
along with it that aren't ideal but the
reality is is that I don't see this
killing the human creative Spirit we
still have to input and I think that's
going to be a big factor thank you
amazing thank you so much thank you
all right Vayner Nation we're continuing
on this podcast live from cam Lions
2023. I'm going to let my next guest
introduce his full name and what he does
and we'll get right into it
um hey I'm Michael wirich and I'm the
co-founder of mindspa what we spotted
early on is that music can affect and
impact people emotionally and could even
heal kind of certain situations in
modern medicine couldn't touch 20 25
minutes you can have a very deep impact
on a person's state of mind on the way
they sleep on their stress level a thing
that I think is a little bit easier for
a human to understand is are they
sleeping well you know you mentioned it
earlier you know a lot of people know me
as like I go hard and I'm who I am but
the reality is I've never compromised on
sleep I will sleep 10 hours a day if
that's I listen to my body very well
this Saturday if I to sleep 14 hours to
like make up for it like I've never
thought like not sleeping is gonna make
me successful it's more while I'm awake
I need to be productive and make [__]
happen sleep is the big one right in
terms of the study and in in terms of
specifically how we recorded the sounds
like nature when you when you get lost
in that and you get it in 3D sound like
your mind is tricked to believe you're
somewhere out there it just helps you
fall into into you give me a cricket and
an owl and I'll show you right sleeping
right within 30 seconds
appreciate you happy to do it
this would be enough for me oh yeah like
give me any the only thing I can't sleep
to is dead silence you keep it natural
stay in your bag like you're wearing
satchels hey baby you a guy saying guys
and just missing the sandals but still
you ain't missing much put your hands on
my back just a different touch but yo
what's on my plate I don't skip the line
shut up skip the brush nothing either
and we had it close not a center me to
get it where do you see the Brand's
place on in Tech talk because it has so
quickly evolved making content that
actually seen to continue to focus on
making actual tick tocks instead of
making ads to distribute on Tick Tock so
our framework on social media creative
is called sock strategic organic content
that s is everything like do you
actually know the creative strategy you
don't need influencers in every post and
making product the star is a good idea
like do you know what's actually working
because this industry in this town this
week is just hyper over the top on the
subjective nature of commercials versus
the strategy a creative practice of
social I think that's the chasm Brands
need to get very serious of like knowing
how to make ads on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook Twitter Youtube like first what
can work on a YouTube short what can
work on a tick tock and then you need to
make as many of those as possible for
the lowest cost as possible to win on as
much relevance as they possibly can
take care
please welcome now to the stage the CEO
and co-founder of vaynermedia Gary
vaynerchuk
[Applause]
the biggest brands in the world that
visit here spend all their time
thinking about tomorrow and yesterday
and because they don't have the ability
to actually know how to Market Today AKA
social media creative and media spends
what do they do they spend all their
money doing M A to buy brands that
actually do today there's not a person
sitting here that I'm looking at that
doesn't realize there's some attention
on social I literally am having
conversations with people already this
week about how social media should be
regulated because it's so powerful
social media is changing the
geopolitical nature of the world and we
are talking about that yet there's not
even going to be a peep about creative
in Social this entire week not an award
not a conversation our industry which is
phenomenal is incredible about being
excited about yesterday and yet sitting
right here in the middle we have brands
that are being built every day within
social creative and media and we
continue to disregard it it is time for
media and creative to come back together
like it wasn't in 1950s 60s 70s 80s and
90s so that we no longer do this and we
stay accountable as agencies and we
actually start delivering for the brands
that pay us and start making content
that people want not what we want to
make subjectively in a boardroom thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
how will the advertising industry be
different 12 months from now if you told
me 14 years later I'd have to be talking
about taking social media seriously I
would have laughed you out of the room
so for me in 12 months I really don't
expect too too much the people that are
watching this right now I'm going to
actually speak to you and put this down
aren't you tired of doing work that you
don't care about that you know nobody's
gonna see like isn't it time for you to
actually take the reins and stop
complaining about working in an
institution that doesn't let you do your
thing if it doesn't let you do your
thing go find one that does or go do it
yourself how is it going to change in 12
months another 100 200 great creative
people are going to leave our industry
because we're not letting them do the
right thing
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much
it's going to be our terrific moderator
can you remember
when you spotted your ability or when
you knew you had the ability to spot
Trends culturally and technologically to
Trends I don't like to look at them from
that perspective because then that means
you're just a trend Hunter I'm
magnetized to things that are synonymous
with my interests as they are spawning
and growing from itty bitty to Big
biggies those folks that are in that
same frequency are going to naturally
gravitate to itty Bitties as they become
big biggies you're going to gravitate to
that before it becomes a trip a
gathering what about what about your
foresight into Innovation I think it
started when you were three YouTube came
out it was about seven eight weeks old
and I started making wine videos I've
never been in front of the camera I
never thought of myself as someone that
humans would know I was running a
business for my family when YouTube sold
to Google for 1.7 billion dollars that
felt like a trillion that was an unheard
of number and it just hit me so hard I'm
like wait a minute I've got something I
have a intuition a curiosity a different
way that I look at things that makes me
understand what a lot of people are
going to be into before they're even
realizing they're into it and that was
the first time I thought I had something
different and I've honed that skill but
the best part of the skill is it's
grounded in genuine curiosity and the
liking of people
[Music]
very well thank you so much thank you
everybody
[Applause]
really every time
never heard of you I'm sorry that's okay
I'm here about coincidence yes I was
inspired to be worse I mean it
completely agree with you I go to see
his evenings a lot it's almost always
it's crap that's right this time
I'm very humbled nice of you to come up
and say that means a lot to me it means
a lot to me what's your name again sir I
think it's not important it's important
to me Mark such a pleasure please I had
never heard of yourself they were so
good that I will do my best in my agency
to get a bit of your spirit that's very
nice of you I'm very humbled by your
words that's very nice I'm telling you
how I feel thank you thank you I got
floaters in my eyeball coasters by the
shot glass smoking let my mind fall
plenty roaches no ass stepping on the
critters just going through my spine
should be used to a state of a poor
man's mind it's just PB no J Kool-Aid no
sugar all in the bath water for warm
showers and winner work cooking [__]
clean mama was a magician she switched
it and turned the tub to a washing
machine air drying their clothes hanging
up with my woes enemies was befriending
me laughing about all my lows but the
song
[Music]